[Music]
johnny's performing in prague today on
his world tour with buddy jeff beck
friday the pair will release 18 their
new album with 13 tracks including two
new songs from depp that seemingly
reference ex amber heard listen to this
one
[Music]
there's more from an unreleased tract
called sad bleeping parade johnny
reportedly sings you're sitting there
like a dog with a seven year itch and if
i had a dime it wouldn't reach your hand
as well as this line i think you've said
enough for one expletive night
[Music]
this comes as amber officially demands a
mistrial a lot of mistakes
we'd be looking at a huge uproar
e.t obtained the new court documents
where amber's attorneys claim her due
process was compromised because juror
number 15 was never summoned to be there
legal expert julie rendellman explains
what they're saying is that the juror
that showed up was 52 years old the
juror that was supposed to be in that
position was actually 77 years old both
individuals had the same name and
address did they intentionally lie if
it's simply a mistake that does not rise
to any claim that would require a
mistrial we feel very confident that
there are no errors that would justify
any kind of successful appeal today
lawyers for johnny responded calling
amber's mistrial request frivolous in
its entirety asking the judge to reject
her outlandish requests meanwhile
amber's getting sued is she able to pay
a 10.4 million dollar judgment oh no
absolutely not herds insurance company
new york marine in general filed docs
arguing they don't have to honor her one
million dollar policy to pay part of
last month's judgment the company claims
it's not liable since a jury ruled that
amber committed a willful act of
defaming johnny it's asking for a trial
the second issue they raise is that the
attorneys that amber heard used during
the trial are not the attorneys that the
insurance company agreed to now the
question is are they going to be
successful if the policy supports the
insurance company then they will be
[Music]